House cobras my name is Pippa welcome
welcome welcome to part 6 of undertale
so a friend of mine helped me replay
most of the the game because I'm too
lazy and he loves undertale so he was
like yes let me do it um I'm still kind
of like pissed off even though I didn't
have to technically replay most of it
myself because it's been days and I
haven't been able to play undertale I
really want to get the right ending of
this and I just [ __ ] up the beginning
we're gonna fight a score again do you
really say a score I'm sure it's like a
score or something or ah it just doesn't
sound right
I'm sorry a score okay so now fly we
won't kill him right I swear to god a
fly we kill a score I will I will kill
flower okay we know the dialogue okay
blah blah blah it's emotional but I've
seen it three times it looks like a
broke what is it fixed again please work
please human oh it's so sweet this part
why am I still skipping it I hate him
well let's get this over with what I
still have to fight him I hate him
ah so he remembers that's so creepy I
hate it I swear to God Toby alright I
guess it's up to me to get your real
happy ending for starters you can't do
it by yourself papyrus undyne alphys
these guys are you friends with all of
them yet maybe you should go back and
hang with them the power of friendship
that always saves the day right why is
he telling me this so oh my god are you
kidding me alright so
I I don't know if I talked to [ __ ] all
right all right all right all right
we're gonna have to befriend everyone
power a friendship I feel like this is a
plot twist he's telling me to do this so
you can kill them as well or some [ __ ]
what about sons can I hang with sons
he seems dope you know his sons remind
me of crying yeah he does a lot all
right I know where Ondine lives sadder
you say Ondine and Undine moon didn't
that can't perhaps all right I'm here
oh the human arrives are you ready to
hang out with our dad I have a plan to
make you two great friends will you hang
out yes okay stand behind me their house
looks so mean make sure you're giving
this she laughs sees what it sardines
oh my mom I love happy pirate ready for
your extra private one-on-one training
you bet I am and I brought a friend
hi I don't think we why don't you two
come in oh boy this is going great
that sword is huge hey I'm Dan my friend
brought a gift for you on that on their
own ha ha thanks I'll uh put it with the
others ha ha ha so over it is Sir wipsy
tipsy I spit everywhere I just
remembered I have to go to the bathroom
you two have fun haha [ __ ] [ __ ]
seems legit ha ha ha
so why are you here you rub your victory
my face you humiliate me even further
is that it No then why are you here
wait I get it you think that I'm gonna
be friends with you huh
right never with you yes really
how delightful I accept let's all frolic
in the field of friendship night why
would I ever be friends with you if
you're my houseguest I'd beat you up
right now you're the enemy of everyone's
hopes and dreams I will never be your
friend like get out of my house
dang what a shame I thought undyne would
be friends with you but I guess it's I
overestimated her she's just not up for
the challenge challenge what my prayers
where ii done it he thinks I can't be
friends with you sure what a joke
I could be friends with a Wimpy loser
like you any day now let's show him
listen up human you're not just going to
be we're not just going to be friends
we're going to be besties I'll make you
like me so much how do I read I don't
know you won't be able to think of
anyone else figure you it's the perfect
revenge why don't you have a seat oh boy
I am sitting down sit down and progress
huh thanks for being clear comfortable I
get you something to drink
what does it put a drink on the stove
I'll set what would you like oh my god
hey don't get up you're the guest sit
down and enjoy yourself sorry um why not
you just point out what you want you can
use a spear I am Megha the stove drink
soda actually even though you pointed to
it you don't look happy
let's find out I think that sort of
grows to brush your teeth it rusts
you're fighting spring huh why do I have
it um what about hot chocolate I want
hot chocolate
wait I just remember the containers
empty I stopped getting it because it
was always as though a skirt kept
getting marshmallow stuck in his beer I
love the way to are to that sugar goes
into tea all right sugar that for the
team I'm not gonna give you a cup of
sugar
what do I look like the ice cream woman
do human ice cream women terrorize
humanity with energy Spears are there
ice cream songs a prelude to destruction
is that it no that's what I thought well
I don't know then what about the tea box
G all right coming right up which I just
picked tea right away Jesus cry I mean
nothing it'll take a moment for the
water to boil a very awkward moment I
would say okay it's all done I like a
Undine has sonic boots
I never realized gotta go so fast maybe
they're related she's blue too
weird-looking careful it's hot I feel
like this friendship is great it's not
that hard just drink you take a sip of
the tea it's burning but other than that
it's pretty good it's pretty good right
nothing but the best for my absolutely
precious friend hey you know it's kind
of strange to choose that tea golden
flower tea that's a scores favorite kind
actually now that I think about it you
kind of remind me of him
you're both total weenies sort of I just
realized I have to beat a score for the
third time I love this theme you know I
was pretty hot-headed kid once to prove
I was the strongest I try to file a
score emphasis untried I couldn't land a
single blow on him and worse the whole
time he refused to fight back I was so
humiliated
afterwards he apologized and said
something goofy excuse me do you want to
know how to beat me I said yes and from
then on he trained me one day during
practice I finally knocked him down
I felt bad but he was beaming I had
never seen someone more proud to get
their butt kick anyway long story short
he kept training me and I'm the head of
the Royal Guard so I'm the one who gets
to Train dorks to fight like um a Paris
he's a dork all right but I'm to be
honest I don't know if I can never let
prepares into the Royal Guard don't tell
him I said that he's just mom I mean
it's not that he's weak he's actually
pretty freaking tough it's just that he
is uh it's too innocent a nice I mean
look he was supposed to capture you and
he ended up being friends with you
instead
I could never send in a battle you get
ribbon he get ripped into little smiling
shreds that's part of why I started
teaching how to cook you know so maybe
he can do something else with his line
well he makes a mean spaghetti mom
spaghetti oh sorry
I was talking for so long you're out of
tee aren't you I get some more wait a
second but Paris it's cooking lesson
he was supposed to have that right now
and if is not air to have it you'll have
to have it for oh god I see what this is
good
oh yeah that's right
nothing has brought the pears and I
closer than cooking which means that if
I give you his lesson will become closer
friends and you can imagine Oh afraid
we're gonna be best friends
damn I'm I am afraid anyway let's start
with the sauce Jesus Christ envision
these vegetables as your greatest enemy
now bound them to dust with your face
how will you power stronger wimpy wimpy
you pet the vegetables and an
affectionate man oh my god it stop
patting the enemy I'll show you how it's
done
yeah Jesus Christ a Talib need a mess on
that beautiful wallpaper uh we'll
describe this into a ball later but for
now we add the dose homemade
know-it-alls are the best but I just buy
store-brand they're the cheapest yeah uh
just put them in a pot egg careful
you place the noodles in one at a time
they Clank against the empty button nice
all right now it's time to stir the
pasta as a general rule of thumb the
more you stir the batter arash ready
let's do it now I am staring this [ __ ]
up alright alright I'm doing it yep
that's pretty hardcore ah let me do it
alright that's your you broke the pot oh
that's the stuff
alright now for the final step turn up
three let the stove top symbolize your
passion now your hopes and dreams turn
into burning fire
I don't all anything back hold right to
turn up the heat
oh boy it's alright alright that's I
think it's gonna burn for this it's it's
definitely on alright [ __ ] sake what
happens oh my god ah man
no wonder prepares sucks of cooking huge
Shh so what's next
scrapbooking friendship bracelets ah Who
am I kidding
I'll really screw this up tonight I
can't force you to like me human some
people don't get along with each other I
understand if you feel that way about me
and if we can't be friends that's ok
because if we're not friends
it means I can destroy you with regret
what I've been defeated my house is in
shambles I even failed to befriend you
that's it I don't care if you're my
guests anymore on Final rematch all out
on both sides it's the only way I can
regain my lost pride now come on hit me
with all you got yeah all right fake
attack you pretend to swing out down
down with all your might
oh [ __ ] I hit her what that's the best
you can manage even attacking at full
force
you just can't muster any intent to hurt
me huh you know what
I don't actually want to read you either
at first I hated your stupid saccharine
shtick but the way you hit me right now
it reminded me of someone I used to
train with now I know you aren't just
some wimpy loser your wimpy loser with a
big heart just like him listen human it
seems that you and asker are fated to
fight but knowing him he probably
doesn't want it talk to him I'm sure you
can persuade him to let him go
eventually some human will mean human
will fall down here and I'll take their
soul instead that makes sense right
oh and Ned you do her task or I'll take
the human souls across the barrier and
beat the hell out of you that's her
friends are for right
oh my let's get the hell out of this
flaming house probably a good idea oh
it's a hole the poor house well that was
fun huh well laughing out in the game
another time but uh somewhere else I
guess in the meantime I'll go and hang
with peppers so if you need me drop by
Snowden alright okay and if you ever
need help just keep prepare us a ring
okay since we're in the same spot I'll
be able to talk to you too well see you
later Punk oh wait this is sudden but
can you hey wait your inventories full
oh well I'll be up a purse can see me
when you have less stuff what what was
he supposed to give me I don't know I
guess we will never know so I guess I'm
supposed to go to Snowden now wait what
is not right
it seems Undine has something for you
she's the person that's me not me oh
thanks for that tip alright so let's
dimensional box let's put away the star
fate
alright hi and dine um so I have a
favorite ask to you um I I need you to
deliver this letter to dr. ralphus huh
why don't I do myself um well it's kind
of personal but we're friends so I'll
tell you hot line sucks I don't want to
go over there so here you go that makes
sense
oh and if you read it I'll kill you
thanks so much
you're the best facial reaction that one
undyne writes a lot of letters but she
can never seem to find the right words
so when she goes to deliver them herself
she always quits so she can go back and
rewrite that's why she asks you because
she you have no standards same reaction
again so I assume that I already had
stayed with the pears then or try to be
his boyfriend or girlfriend I don't I
don't want to talk about it so let's
move on to Alfie's and talk to her oh no
is that on the letter I don't want to
open it
can I just slide it back out no I can't
keep doing this I'll read this one um
it's shut kind of strong Liz in it wait
a second
what a chainsaw oh my god hey if this is
a joke it's oh my god did you write this
letter it wasn't signed so I had no idea
what could have oh my god oh no that's
adorable
and I had no idea you wrote that way
it's surprising - after all the gross
stuff I did I don't really deserve to be
forgiven much less
this and so passionately - you know what
okay I'll do it
it's the least I can do to make up to
you so he thinks that we are hitting on
her I mean uh yeah let's go on a date oh
god where's this dating start oh sorry
still haha still getting dressed
now that now that is some hot [ __ ] we're
out we are in hot lands after all my
friend helped me pick out this dress she
got a great sense of anyway let's do
this thing
dating sorry hey hey wait actually we we
can start the date yet um I gotta give
you items to raise your affections
stitch it wait are we live [ __ ] oai
or whatever I never been on this is the
end of the dating spectrum what the [ __ ]
that'll increase the chance of a
successful outcome to the date right
anyway don't worry I'm prepared
I will stockpiling gift in anticipation
for a day like this okay okay you can't
be walking around like that I love you
but I'm dating people first I've got
some metal armor polish maybe you can't
use that but I also brought some
waterproof cream for your scales you're
okay it's meant for Undine isn't it um
well how about this magical spear repair
kit that I uh
hey let's forget about the items let's
just start the day finally yeah let's uh
date
do you like anime yes I do
hey me too hey let's go somewhere but
where's a good place to go on a date I
got it let's go to the garbage damn yep
you got it
oh boy here we are this is where Undine
I come all the time we find all sorts of
great stuff here hey she is really oh no
that's her over there I can't let her
see me on a date with you why because uh
well oh no here's your Kem's oh my god
this is starting to a love drama all the
sudden like what the hell am i doin away
hey there you are
um I realized if you deliver that thing
it might be a bad idea so I'm gonna do
it give it to me oh you don't have it ha
have you at least seen her uh no no but
she wasn't at home where that could she
be oh my god well I guess it's obvious
huh I really like her I mean more than I
like other people I'm sorry I just
figured you know it'd be fun to go on
like a cute kind of pretend date with
you to make you feel better oh come on
why is everyone so condescending to me
in this game Jesus Christ
well it sounds even worse when I put it
like that yeah it does I'm sorry I
messed up again
undines the person I I might I really
want to go on a date with but I mean
she's way out of my league
I thought you aren't I'm cool but I'm
dying she's so confident strong and
funny and I'm just nobody fraud
the Royal scientists but all I ever done
is hurt people I told her so many lies
she thinks she thinks I'm a lot cooler
than I actually am if she gets close to
me she'll she'll find out the truth
about me what should I do
kill her the truth the truth but if I
tell her the truth she'll hate me isn't
it better this way to live a lie where
both people are happy or true for
neither of us are they say be yourself
but I don't really like who myself is I
rather just be whatever makes people
like me oh no you're right every day I'm
scared scared of what would happen if
people in the truth on their own they'll
all get hurt because of me
but how can I tell undyne the truth I
don't have the confidence I'm gonna mess
it up how do I practice let's roleplay
it obviously let's roleplay roleplay
that actually sounds kind of fun all
right
which which one of us will be on time um
I'll be lying down obviously all right
obviously um hi Undine how are you today
I'm fine haha
glad to hear it ah so I like to talk
about something uh then she
what is it alphys now you see I haven't
been exactly truthful with you
you see I am I'll forget it
undyne I want to tell you how I feel
you're so brave and strong and nice you
always listen to me when I talk about
nerdy stuff you always do whatcha make
me feel special like selling me out
you'll beat up anyone that gets in my
way
undone I can't take this any longer
I'm madly in love with you hold me under
hold me
what did you just say and a knight I was
just hey wait a second your outfits
really cute what's the occasion
she actually think is cute okay wait a
second are you two on a date uh yes I
mean oh no I mean I mean actually we
were only romantically role-playing as
you what I mean
I mean I'm Diane I I've been lying to
you
what about what about well everything I
told you that see would was I really
just used it on ice cream and those few
minutes are a and ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
Alfie's I just wanted to impress see I
just wanted you to think I was smart and
cool that I wasn't some nerdy loser I'll
fish I'm dying I really think you're
neat all right Alfie's Shh oh [ __ ]
Alfie I figure need to I guess but you
got to realize most of what you said
really doesn't matter to me I don't care
if you're watching kid cartoons or
reading history books to me all that
stuff is nerdy crap what I like about
you is that you're passionate your
analytical it doesn't matter what it is
do you care about it 100 percent of
maximum power so you don't have to lie
to me I don't want you to lie it'll to
lie to anyone anymore alphys I want to
help you become happy with who you are
and I know just the training you need to
do that enjoy you you're gonna train me
what me oh my god now I'm gonna get
prepared to do it
get those bone-shaking s time to doing
the lap tune about a great we are ready
I'm about to start a timer
undyne I'll do my best and then san oh
my god she was kidding right those
cartoons those comics are just still
real right anime is real right anime is
not real and no enemy is real uh-huh I
knew it
gigantic sword magical princess here I
come um thanks for taking care of Ali's
I didn't get to say what I want him to
but she seems like things seem like
they're going to get better for her well
I got to catch up with him later
what just happened
alright what is it Oliver in the
junkyard so so save that didn't work out
um if we the data prepares which I think
we have hmm and we've ad dated Alfie's
and technically and Oh howdy
if it isn't my good friend new just me
this is my parasol so you're my
girlfriend
outfits and I finished our training
early very early should I send her home
very home uh now I feel strongly and for
no apparent really reason you should
also go back to her lab house I have
only good feelings about this goodbye
click all right well and the game
clearly tells us what to do next so I
suppose we shall do that let's take the
tralala man to the trololol and
travel walk every ride yes to hot line
please now we're off can we please get a
pun on the way god I record these like
six six because I record other videos
during the day and God
I get hungry the waters are while today
that's good luck I am starving so if I
don't seem very energetic because I need
a Snickers right I had a Nature Valley
crunch sponsor not really
I think bad for you I feel like they're
so sweet like they have to be bad and
they're they're just kind of marketed to
be like good for you because it's like
nature crunch but there's no way more
like no way churro crunch alright we're
in the lab um happen here that was there
before that's a little creepy
oh she must be what did we take this rap
before what is this
no we must have taken his rap yeah and I
remember okay my bad bayaud dead um up
the thing yes oh she's working on
mettaton oh yeah she made medicine I
love marathon let's talk to marathon
make that done met that down met the
term with the term at the dome at the
thumb at the dump met the thumbs met the
thumb at the tone with the dome at the
tone so kawaai those I met this on his
undergoing repairs at La Melton I want
to be minted on cigar I met a toe jam um
dog food
right surely it's and no I want about
the note it's a note okay read it it's
hard to read because I had reading but
you try your best
hey thanks for your help back there you
guys support really means a lot to me
but you guys alone can't medical make my
problems go away
I want to be a better person I'm gonna
be afraid anymore and for that to happen
I have to be able to face my own
mistakes I might going to start doing
that now I want to be clear this isn't
anyone else's problem but mine but if
you don't ever hear from me up again if
you want to know the truth enter the
door to the north of this note you all
at least deserve to know what I did to
the Norv how did you know what we know
the North is you should ascend up
alright
that would have made a lot more sense oh
my god oh great
oh I'm sure that's great no that's
that's what an elevator is for right
that sound like a drop dubstep beat drop
than an elevator drop drop so I don't
here we go alright let's go hello oh god
this is creepy Alfie's what did you do
this is that time to do what the King
had asked me to do I will create the
power to free us all I will unleash the
power of the soul enter number two the
barrier is locked by soul power
unfortunately this power cannot be art
Rick created artificially soul power can
only be derived from what was once
living so to create more we will have to
use what we have now the souls of
monsters God Alfie's enter number three
the extracting but it struck me a soul
from a living monster would require
incredible power
besides being impractical doing so would
instantly destroy the souls host and
unlike the persistent souls of humans
the souls of the most monsters disappear
immediately upon death
if only I could make a monster so last
Alfie's number five I've done it using
the blueprints I've extracted it from
the human cells I believe this is what
gives our souls the strength to persist
after that you will the will to keep
living the result to change fate let's
call this power determination ooh oh boy
am I filled with determination and empty
with hunger power room this is really
keeping going
I got what do you want just get
comfortable and get funky with it come
on sit down buddy come on we're gonna go
you're gonna get food - I'm hungry - all
right there you go so cute and enter
number six a score ask everyone outside
the city for monsters that had fallen
down there bodies came in today there's
still comatose and soon they'll all turn
into dust but what happens if you inject
determination into them freedom might be
closer than we all thought Oh alphys
you're so nave enter number nine things
aren't going well none of the bodies
have turned into dust so I can't get
souls
I told their families that I would give
them the dust back to the funerals for
the funerals people are starting to ask
me what's happening what do I do
how much time passed
why don't I hit the switch why am I
doing this
oh why uh is it Napster Luke that's
creepy
oh god it's like that Pokemon with no
name you know when you glitched it out
that Pokemon Chi the unnamed one oh god
please don't
oh it's definitely inspired by that I
feel like this game is like a mix of
like Homestuck Pokemon and human iki
Niki you arrived
smells like batteries I think it's
really cool cuz this game kind of like I
feel like oh god that's creepy come join
the fun ah I've got it I could die here
if I [ __ ] up
um this game really bridged the gap with
the origin that
JRPGs like a band like the witch house
because those are like amazing story
based games in the kind of same format
uh but I mean they're not on Steam or
anything
whatever that means I think I should
refuse but this game really did it hit
the hit that mainstream yow um seems
like it doesn't care anymore all right
did it and that's the red switch cool
it's impressive what they did with the
game okay
wait did we press the switch okay and
yes alright the door should be open now
ah pj kick the pj he played the game
recently as well and he he's obsessed
with it
and he said like they're they ending you
have to play it the real ending the
pacifist ending i told the families that
I would give them oh yeah we read this
no way to let up again I guess it just
lit up with you walk by them oh god
there's a lot of switches okay that's
fine I enjoy puzzles um god I'm so
hungry though enter number 12
nothing is happening I don't know what
to do I'll just keep injecting
everything with determination I want
this to work
yeah well alright entry number 13 one of
the bodies open his eyes Oh creepy
named dog food ball ah no Alfie's engine
number 15 seems like the Reach's was
dead end but at least we got a happy
ending out of it it's I sent the souls
back gasps cord returned the vessels to
its garden and I called all of the
families and told them everyone's alive
and I'll send everyone back tomorrow
smiley face creepy
Andrew number 16 no no no God so I go
God god damn that's creepy oh god no
well maybe this is a nipple huh
well I was on the climatic uh I'm good
I glued like all these things on the
wall with it Oh God
it's not an actual monster God it is oh
I guess I'll cry oh no oh boy unhook
that thing um well anyway I got you glue
them with a spray and the spray it's
starting to come it's left in the room
in it it's making my nostrils like a
little stuck together I don't think it's
healthy for me to be in here right now I
hope I don't pass out oh god I hope I
don't die more than that actually
I'm point do I suck
let's eat some more surfing ah come on
I guess I'll scream come on I don't want
to die boom yeah this is going vain what
call oh my god I keep making the same
mistakes I'm gonna run out of Starfy
come on flex this is a boss battle I
hope so
thank God that was dis awkward
okay well we need oh god it's dark isn't
it if you google a human Ikki the main
character looks almost identical uh then
then I say that yeah I think I said it
see the glue is messing up with my brain
it's cool to see the inspiration think
what am i doing in here
I'm holding up at the same time hoping I
will go into something
I need an item to be here maybe huh oh
we did it somehow sorry I forgot to read
the note
okay I guess we go back now
and now we can go down here and another
button how we don't have the yellow
Bunya Oh God haha Solaris what is this
just gory wake up
what is it de and why do you have that
video camera Shh
I don't want I want to get your reaction
gory juice what is my favorite vegetable
hmm carrots right no no no my favorite
vegetable is edamame I love it a moment
get it oh god I caught it go back to bed
dear
no no not yet now if I were a dog what
breed of dog would I be hmm I don't know
honey what kind of dog would you be I
would be a mom Iranian ha
you sure are excited to have the chance
you know if you keep making jokes like
this one day you could be a famous mum
Radian well now I'm gonna bet hey come
on Toria that one was funny I know I was
just teasing you
goodnight dear goodnight honey oh dear i
purr perhaps it is too dark in here for
the video camera to come out yeah we
didn't see it so can we see something
now howdy
yes smile for the camera huh this time I
got you
I left the cap on on purpose now you're
smiling for no reason what oh yeah
remember when we try to make
butterscotch pie for dad right
the recipe asked for butter but we
accidentally put butter cups instead
yeah those flowers got it really got him
real sick I felt bad so felt so bad we
made mom really upset
I should have laughed it off like you
did um anyway where are you going with
this uh turn off the camera
okay I got five and four left and why do
i click five before four kids can you
hear me I want you to wake up Pierce you
have to stay determined you can't give
up there are if you are the future of
humans and monsters kids please wake up
I don't like this plan anymore I know I
said I said I'd never doubt you six
right we just have to get the six and
we'll do it together right well there's
no six oh wait I don't like this idea
Pitts no I I not big kids Tonka oh sorry
yeah we saw this one
I'll say they were researching humans Oh
shaggy icon it says under the sheets
maybe I should look under their sheets
under the sheets under the sheets
badda-badda badda-badda but under the
sheet under the sheets to shoot to shoot
let's do the one that seems like
different that's creepy
what the [ __ ] yes there it is
boom bada bing bada boom bada badda
bodda bope all right cool progress might
set call me we're doing takeaway tonight
so I am very excited because I'm very
hungry
but I'm also loving playing this game
and I hope I can end this episode on
like a decent part at least not that it
matters to you because you just click
next part anyway I think we got all the
switches and all the [ __ ] let's go
here anyway just check out there's the
flowers what's with the flowers entry
number 7 we'll need a vessel after all
can have our monsters ok I don't really
care I'm sorry
sting too much reading for me
kaliesha it feels a little cliche I'm
not gonna lie alright okay that's creepy
oh god this is like rare pokemons I
guess I'll clean it you wash your hands
oh god that is terrifying what's gonna
happen it's gonna shoot it at me isn't
it oh my god what just happened you hum
a familiar tune but no one heard you oh
okay here it comes
damn it let's pick on it seems effective
yeah no I I know all about that attack I
do that all the time
mystify you did something mysterious
recognize it has more to learn from this
one why this is like a mix of all the
levels like froggit right how about we
pray you kneel and pray Reaper virus
seems to remember something something
finally gets it
someone finally get ribbit ribbit oh boy
oh boy it's getting difficult
seems to me flat flat whatever that owe
you one alright
oh we don't have the blue switch all
right
cold so maybe in a fridge or something
let's see if we can find it I'm sure we
can oh boy oh boy oh boy did we see a
fridge summer I don't think we walk this
way yeah this is definitely cold this is
very creepy what happens if we hit it
she blows away the steam and it creates
another enemy oh that's not good
I didn't heal well I guess we have no
choice
oh that's cool I like that one
let's play with it it reminds me of it
you know that day that game that I
played a long time ago would like
alpacas oh that's so cute we won
okay we got all the switches now
correct yes I think where was the blue
switch again was it down here I don't
remember
my memory is impeccable I got I must say
my body is also asleep I am complaining
a lot
welcome to me when I'm hungry all right
I'm not the most fun to be around what
[ __ ] did I get the [ __ ]
switch jesus [ __ ] christ what do you
want from me [ __ ] hell oh I gotta
have a noodle with pork broth mm-hmm
it's waiting for me at home it's gonna
be so good I'm sorry is that
inappropriate no all right I'm just
gonna check all these [ __ ] fans maybe
I needed to put the fan on to get rid of
the smoke in the other room but maybe I
just did it anyway I am well confused
what is that I don't like my ab score oh
here's a fridge well then could have
saved a lot of time and effort this one
seems to be moving never mind this one
this one why are they all empty shot up
yeah I know you're not empty got a
refrigerator monster or what it what is
this prop hunt well that looks pretty
trippy let's make a joke you told the
bad pun about snow
her expression starts to shift
it's too cold let's laugh you laugh and
keep laughing it's so funny you can't
stop tears run down your face what why
did you do that
snowy well that's awkward heckle you
said something like you look horrible
why are you even live what you didn't
say with that what am I supposed to do
here and I won okay I have no more
questions why high quality curtain I am
so confused
I'm sure I'm tired guys all right I'm um
I'm a man who likes to eat food three
times a day
alright that's I don't oh all right
I'm gonna put the light switch then
we're gonna end it there but don't and
huh make it huh and it make a dream come
true wait all in this for me in you I
think I just did something awful yes I
did thank you very very much
what's look cute I hope they are friends
I love friends oh my dad is calling me
why am i so popular hey stop I get it
hey bye bye
um counting at home to Femina there okay
Mia yeah take a meeting on family time
okay brah hey okay sorry about that that
kind of gets they get kind of sassy when
they don't get fed on time oh my god
it's like me anyway the power went out
and I've been trying to put it back on
but it seems like you were on step ahead
of me but this probably is just a big
inconvenience for you but I appreciate
that you came here to back me up as I
said I was afraid I might not come back
but there's not because of these guys or
anything I was just worried I would be
too afraid to tell the truth I might run
away or do something cowardly I a
suppose I owe you an explanation as you
probably know as go ask me to study the
nature of souls during the research
isolator a power I called their
termination I injected it into dying
monsters so their souls would last after
death but the experiment failed you see
unlike humans monsters bodies don't have
enough physical matter to take the
concentrations of determination their
bodies start to melt and I lost what
physically physicality they had pretty
soon all the test subjects have melted
together into those seeing them like
this I knew I couldn't tell their
families about it I couldn't tell anyone
about it no matter how much everyone was
asking me and I was too afraid to do any
more work knowing of everything I'd done
so far I've been such a horrific failure
but now now I changed my mind about all
this I'm gonna tell us how everyone what
I've done it's gonna be hard being
honest believing in myself I'm sure
there will be times where I'll struggle
I'm sure there will be times where I
screw up again but knowing deep down
that I have friends to fall back on I
know it'll be a lot easier to stand on
my own thank you that is adorable
come on guys it's time for everyone to
go home that is the cutest thing I have
ever seen in my entire life
so I just go back home Oh God
Oh No Alfie what did you do ring it's a
voice you've never heard before parents
are you there it's been a long time
hasn't it but you've done well thanks to
you everything's fall into place pits
see you soon Oh
and now we face a final challenge wait I
don't have to walk this way do I I can
just take the elevator
yeah I don't know how many times I've
walked in circles here yep
then just walk down here if you get a
lot there's no same there okay that's
not good um I hope we don't have to
fight Isaac or again cuz I don't wanna
kill him it's so sad every time I am
very much hoping for a savefile right
now I'm not gonna lie I I will cry tears
of joy still I don't see a [ __ ] save
file
there should be one here there is not it
is not there should be one here thank
you
breast you know you're beautiful I will
see in the next one
professed